the people went to gft prison they
are the star cows
[Music]
then
[ __ ] bottle
wow
these phases
no
bye
I don't know how
fans
h
[ __ ] where
ah
bárcenas
no right
swayze
here from hardware
nothing
canaries
ergo it
's nothing
that is
oak
be
and of course
sweet airs
if you spend
the image of the faction and the exterior
here
the energy
as
clarifies that he led
to sing
and psychology
in it
for kenya then
younes
and to
the one that has finished diverse
months
think about it
here why
m
and the
boy wants  to do
nm
it was carried out today
uruguay
m
there is software
now they reach where the light is,
that is a bed
nothing
also much more
here it would be
the bed
so that nobody
with cesc
I don't know
for a new prosecutor and maite was
yes safe
costs
this faculty
well
efe  jr
what's up
bieber
taxi digs
miss page
city
[Music]
and fell
i
young
[ __ ]
better than there is
situation
and
7 m
also claimed to
download a hundred
more on table
[Music]
and
the fax  now
here
the
survivor
for
general bernal
[Music]
cárcar cat
waiting here
yes
exxon
the guest
mateo
this afternoon
from valència
here
[Music]
your face
yes
and one stays a little strong
7 specifically the mail
as  when he eats a
party
and
dad
the mind
has to be done
and
[Music]
says peter has
put fac
what is he going
to 27 mugabe slips
today I know who he is
[Music]
ah
what are you talking about
or well
and nothing
they tell me that
if you yell
at the comfort
person carmen evans
it costs more
d sometimes it falls
and unloads wave hérner
asian
and more
ma why
shanghai sprinkler
with the help of a month
gastón baquero
and beyond